Welcome to my busy day in the life.
I'm gonna start by cooking some poached eggs for the kids.
Just cleaned and polished the stove.
Time to relight the pilot light.
I think poached eggs are my favourite type of egg.
But I do prefer them from restaurants
when I don't have to put all the effort in to get the reward.
Best poached egg I ever ate was from the Ruby Slipper in New Orleans.
I have a busy day ahead today,
as with every other day here.
My mother in law is telling me
that the air conditioning is leaking underneath the house.
I can smell something from the events,
so we went to investigate and it's bad news.
While she deals with that,
I'm gonna go ahead and go to the lawyer's office
and get me some coffee.
And then I head to my doctor's for some vein surgery.
When I got home, my daughter decided to knot a comb up in her hair.
Once I detangled the comb,
I thought I would try to suck out the trip line
for the air conditioner.
This is absolutely nothing.
I'm just wasting my time.
The water did throw up on the underneath the house,
so that was a plus. We will have to re address that later.
Why don't you pick a beanie in there?
River was enjoying helping me with the air conditioner
and checking out the garden.
Pushing down a little bit so I can see.
Since We're all outside. I decided that we should practice cricket.
I think it's important for the kids
to know a little bit about their heritage
and to learn some British sports
one more time.
I have some great memories of playing cricket with my dad as a kid.
Then it's time to go inside and make some dinner.
I am not in the mood to cook,
but I will cook some food
because we live in the middle of nowhere and I don't have much choice.
I had a marinating piece of flank steak in the fridge,
so we went for that.
We have hardly any meat left.
We have a quarter of a cow on back order
and we're waiting for that to be butchered as we speak.
Then it's time to milk Cora and get all these kids in the bath.
I'm gonna sit here on the toilet while they get a bath
and then I'm gonna go to bed.